Dragon shocking pass revealed his Godly
devil fruit the fate of jinny and Kuma
Luffy's mother and more will be
addressed in this one so make sure to
stay tuned for this epic chapter CH py
King within and smash that like button
if you enjoy seeing these chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming
make this the video you join the knock
if you haven't already by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications with just one
click of a button you can help us reach
your insane goal of 2 million
subscribers here on YouTube and I would
be eternally grateful for that and now
without further Ado let's TR into this
chapter called Jenny spoilers and all we
pick up again with Jenny and Kuma who
had escaped the sorbet Kingdom and were
crying from the happiness of their
simple lives which they could fully
appreciate because they've been through
so much here we have 8 years after the
god Valley incident 30 years ago from
the present and yes this is unfortunate
because we are not getting to see a much
desired continuation of the god Valley
flashback I think we will get to see
what happened next at some point but at
this point it was more like a tease but
it was made clear that we were following
Kuma from the beginning and since he's
not there anymore the story has just
followed him so 8 years after the most
epic of historical events Kuma is now 17
years old and has become a pastor he is
healing the poor elderly in the country
by removing the pain from their bodies
using his devil fruit Powers the people
call it the Miracle hand we saw
something similar when he did it with
Luffy and Zoro took the pain we'll come
back to that but for now we also see
Jenny now 21 years old and she is
looking good it must be said she still
has a similar personality and schools
the elders camping inside the church and
seems to be very popular among the boys
we're told not surprising the citizens
say that the new king of the sorbet
Kingdom King beui is a heartless and
cheap Skate King he even makes the sick
pay tribute the king is listening to
their conversation through a snail wire
tap and blushing a classic example of a
bad king and a human that stands in
stark contrast to Kuma and Kuma's good
heart Kuma says to the people that he
can heal them every week as long as it's
just a slight sickness or pain we see
after the people leave the church that
Kuma is waving them off with a smile on
his face then we see the giant bubble of
pain he pushed out of the elders like
the one Zoro took for Luffy and that
part makes a lot more sense now Kuma
takes this pain in and he's been taking
in that pain to make people feel better
he wasn't being unnecessarily cruel when
he made Zoro take the pain in as we'll
get into shortly jinny is crying and
says Kuma does this every week and the
people don't know that suffering to cure
them Kuma though being the amazing
Pastor he is says it can't be helped
because someone should take all the pain
and suffering that was removed or it
won't disappear if he leaves the pain
alone it will eventually go back to
whoever he removed it from Kuma says
he's happy because everyone he helped
was happy so as I mentioned in
retrospect this shines new light on when
he got Zoro to take in his Captain's
pain the fact is if he didn't it would
have gone back to Luffy and furthermore
at 17 he was taking pain in every week
so he probably felt like Zoro could
handle it very cool that Oda circled
back to this fan favorite moment where
quote unquote nothing happened and added
even more context to it for us Jenny
doesn't like it but she always helps
take care of Kuma after he suffers the
pain and despite the pain they are still
living in happiness after all these
years together so then we jump into 25
years ago and Kuma is 22 and jinny is 26
jinny is getting older and thus
pressuring Kuma to marry her now Kuma
refuses though jinny is furious and
still pressures him but we can
understand his thinking he obviously
loves her and wants them to be happy but
he fears that what happened to his dad
and mom will happen to them and
specifically to Jenny he wants to keep
her safe and marrying her is putting her
life in danger not to mention the life
of their future children now the chapter
starts really getting hyped because when
he changes the subject Kuma changes the
subject to Dragon whose untattooed face
is in the newspaper it's news about
dragon and the freedom Army as it's
called right now Kuma says dragon is
cool and must be a hero hero Kuma says
he wants to go out to the Sea someday
and save many people that's the way he
wanted to live his life we get a funny
throwback to the chapter before and
those two kids who bullied Kuma are
adults now they bring fish to Kuma and
jinny and it's clear that they both have
a crush on Jenny but the question is
will dragon have a crush on her too
because as we're about to see both Kuma
and her will join the Revolutionary Army
so now we jump into 22 years ago where a
big incident happened now Kuma has his
trademark hat and he can no longer be
the gentle giant you can see that
reality has caught up with him now his
once Bright Eyes now have bags around
them the 25-year-old Kuma is telling the
king's Army to release the people they
kidnapped the kidnappers say the law has
changed funny how easily laws can change
despite how unfair those changes can be
OD really does a good job of capturing
just how messed up governments can be in
this case it was stated that southern
people can be quote unquote used however
the privileged Northerners want to use
them the current King believes that this
will make sorb Kingdom Prosper Kuma
knows that he's going to make these
people who are his neighbors friends his
followers at the church slaves so he
gets angry and finally attacks with an
urs's shock unfortunately he doesn't
just Crush everyone he and then
eventually jinny and the two former
bullies end up in jail for having fought
even jinny is beat up which obviously
bothers us but we can only imagine how
much it bothers Kuma as well it's
explained how the sorb kingdom becomes a
kind of microcosm of the world
government AKA a mini world government
where the the Northerners are considered
the true sorbet Kingdom and the South
who is full of people who can't pay the
tribute pretty much lose all their
rights and become slaves but then the
hypeness really takes off and delivers
on that promise of dragon's picture
earlier the freedom Army as it's known
at this point appears and attack SB
Kingdom and deposes the corrupt King
Dragon and old friend Ivanov appear
Ivanov says Hey Kuma if you're still the
same person as back then let's go and
change the world end quote such a hype
moment there's something about just
coming and rescuing someone from prison
who's been wrongly accused and just yeah
it's it's always a hype moment and since
this is pretty much what Kuma said he
wanted it's not surprising that he joins
the Army we're told that the freedom
Army came along with the pirate era and
the traged of oara and was led by the
two pillars dragon and Ivanov so Ivanov
definitely getting some love here as
well and Kuma gets some love next as
we're told that with the addition of
Kuma it transformed into revolutionary
Army that reverberated throughout the
world so Kuma was presented as an
important missing piece that made the
Revolutionary Army what it is today
jinny although this chapter is named
after her isn't presented as that big of
a deal for revolutionary Army but we are
told she joins revolutionary Army too so
here we got dragon and Jenny who has
similar characteristics to Luffy at the
Revolutionary Army at the same time and
as we'll see they spend quite a bit of
time in the Revolutionary Army together
now yes it would be weird after all that
buildup for Jenny to not be with Kuma
but if Kuma kept saying no to protect
her her who knows what might have
happened the math definitely works for
Jenny to potentially be Luffy's mother
too and the chapter is named after her
as well showing she is important just
some food for thought back to Dragon and
he says they still lack funds a big
problem for the Revolutionary Army in
general he wants the Army to help the
Rebellion factions of countries who want
to depose their kings he also wants to
train new recruits so they know how to
fight and handle weapons Dragon then
drops the big bombshell he was a marine
back in the day it gives us a lot to
think about with GARP and everything he
at first followed his Father's Footsteps
potentially trained under him but
finally decided that he couldn't find
Justice there in the Marines Kuma says
he will follow dragon and dragon says he
won't make him regret that decision but
something that's going to happen by the
end of this chapter may make that
sentence a lie Kuma still goes back from
time to time to visit his church eight
more years past AKA we are 14 years from
the present got to say a young dragon
looks very cool and G is looking better
than ever too doesn't look like she's
aging at all really and we'll Circle
back to that like Luffy she's always
seen smiling and eating I believe she's
like 37 now and Luffy would have already
been born by the way this would explain
why she's not in his life too if she
were his mother because she's still
helping the revolutionaries with dragon
in fact she is now the East Army
Commander she is very happy because they
will be joining with Kuma Squad the next
day then at the Revolutionary Army HQ
someone reports to dragon that Ging was
kidnapped the one who reported said
there was an unexpected enemy oh dear
lord the level of cliffhanger there is
crazy the narrator's note is just
disturbing news end quote at this point
Dragon looks very grave lines on his
eyes sweating you can't picture Dragon
looking more devastated he has his
tattoo over his face now again you can
say his expression shows how important
she was to him and how close they've
gotten over the years but Oda has left
the door open for other possibilities
and it is possible Dragon would be this
devastated for any of his comrades if
they were kidnapped either way this
chapter did not hurt the jinny could be
Luffy's mom Theory but of course there
is so much Kuma and Jenny shipping that
it would be kind of weird I admit that
another thing to keep in mind is that in
Bonnie's case her age was never
confirmed it is just estimated to be
currently 24 but because of her ability
it's anyone's guess and the fact that
Oda made sure to say it's an estimation
in the SPs means it's probably not going
to be that because he could have just
given us her age if he wanted to since
he didn't I'm thinking it will be
important to the plot and I got to say I
love this chapter for all the dragon
info we got the fact that he was a
marine had a significant history with
Jenny had to deal with her being
kidnapped and everything we already know
quite a bit about dragon's Powers too we
obviously know that dragon's got to be
strong when we look at his position who
his father and son are but a big reason
his worst criminal in the world bounty
has to be ridiculously high in my
opinion is because because as Robin
pointed out while Pirates usually don't
attack the government or Navy on their
own dragon and the revolutionaries
directly challenge them we're told the
government is angry and continuously
searching for Dragon but to no avail the
fact that dragon has been able to avoid
capture and even continue to act for so
long while directly challenging the
world government as we saw in this
flashback shows how much of a threat he
truly is and probably hints to his
double fruit as we'll get to we're
further told that he is a man of mystery
and no one knows anything about him but
thankfully we're starting to learn that
now we do know that he appeared when it
looked like smoker had captured Luffy
during chapter 100 and by doing so he
helps Luffy Escape when asked why he
helped Luffy he simply said what reason
would I have to get in the way of
another man's Voyage smoker knew the
government was after his head and yet we
didn't even see him try to capture
Dragon probably knowing that he was
outmatched or dragon's devil fruit as
will get into made it impossible
furthermore after Ivanov saved Luffy and
found out out that he was dragon's son
he thought that that would explain
Luffy's almost superhuman Vitality
another subtle nod to Dragon strength we
have good clues for speculating about
Monkey D dragon's possible devil fruit
as well there's reason to believe that
he has a wind-based loia fruit or a more
generally weather-based power the wind
examples are most obvious when he steps
in to save Luffy from smoker there are
suddenly huge gusts of wind that spread
through the town and even shatter Rock
the gusts of wind helped Luffy Escape
then during chapter 587 in a flashback
when Luffy and Ace are surrounded by
Flames suddenly a path is opened up
leading to the Revolutionary ship the
too good to be true path could have been
easily created with the help of dragon's
powerful gusts of wind then during
chapter 794 we see Dragon grab sabo's
hand after the latter's Shipwreck and
then he later appears on his ship being
told he is late and we can see what
looks like wind coming off of him the
ability to turn into wind and transport
using wind explains how he could
suddenly swoop into save Sabo and it
would explain why trying to capture him
is so difficult if not pointless because
he could use his powers to escape from
practically every situation however
we've also seen rain a company dragon
and specifically it's hard to believe
that the lightning that saved Luffy from
his execution was a coincidence as well
especially since Dragon was present so
rather than a straightforward wind loia
fruit there are also theories that he
could have a well dragon fruit to match
his name you might think that's too many
dragon fruits but even kaido's dragon
fruit is a fish fish fruit so it's
definitely still within the realm of
possibility specifically it could be a
mythical zone of a type of Eastern
Dragon called a weather Lord weather
Lords are set to control the weather
clouds and winds and bring lifegiving
rain to the land that last part sounds
especially fitting for revolutionary
they can also summon a storm when
angered and keep in mind it suddenly
started raining when Goldie Roger a dude
who loved Freedom was executed and
dragon was present there too so although
it's all a theory this latter Theory
could fit more of the strange
occurrences we've seen than just a
straightforward wind loia fruit let me
know what you think about the nature of
dragon's devil fruit even though we've
seen a lot of its powers but whatever
ends up being the case I'm sure Oda
won't disappoint especially after
keeping Dragon shatter in mystery for so
long it's good to see him finally giving
us more and more about Dragon back to
the chapter and I can't wait to see what
happens next who the kidnapper was and
what exactly happens to Jenny it would
be crazy if Bonnie was Jenny who ended
up getting the Aging fruits somewhere
along the line and Kuma is her father
AKA Pastor since people refer to the
leader of a church as father it would
obviously still explain why she cares so
much for Kuma since they are still like
family but then Bonnie AKA Jenny could
also be Luffy's mother potentially yes I
know that's probably way too much of a
stretch but that would be a crazy twist
you have to admit if you enjoyed
learning more about the revolutionaries
then you don't want to miss my all
revolutionary commanders and their
powers explained video link on screen
right now like And subscribe to help us
reach our insane goal of 2 million
subscribers here on YouTube and I'll see
you in the next one